all the stars that shine at night are
driven by Fusion Energy it's what powers
the universe
the challenge is how do we take that
enormous object and that enormous power
and recreate those conditions here on
Earth if we can do that we can supply
civilization with the energy it needs to
develop in a way that it removes the
scarcity of energy as a factor in how we
develop this Human Society
hello I'm Simon Mundy I'm a journalist
at the ft and I recently spent two years
traveling through 26 countries exploring
the race to respond to climate change
all over the world in this film we dig
into one of the hottest and most
controversial topics within the push for
cleaner energy one that has received a
burst of fresh publicity in the last few
months fusion power
[Music]
let's begin in the south of France with
what is by many measures the biggest and
most expensive scientific experiments in
human history
[Music]
this is ITA or to give it its full name
the international thermonuclear
experimental reactor
ETA is a joint project among the world's
superpowers trying to harness the
awesome power of nuclear fusion to usher
in a new age of safe clean and massively
abundant energy
[Music]
together the EU us Russia China India
Japan and South Korea have contributed
tens of billions of dollars and
thousands of scientists to the project
its Origins date back to 1985 with a
historic meeting between U.S presidents
Ronald Reagan and Soviet leader Mikhail
Gorbachev
since the 1940s scientists from their
countries and others had been developing
enormously powerful bombs using Fusion
Energy which were many times more
powerful than the weapons dropped on
Japan in 1945. in Geneva the two leaders
set out a vision to collaborate on
fusion power for peaceful purposes
Street
particularly
there is
it took years to gather the full
International Coalition behind the ETA
project which was formally launched in
2007.
in the 15 years since then vast sums
have gone into building a fusion reactor
in the French region of Provence a huge
structure that will be taller than
paris's Arc de Triomphe covering the
area of 60 football pitchers progress
has been slower and more difficult than
anticipated
the idea when it was formed was to bring
you know cultures and Nations that have
been the past sometimes at odds with
each other together in fact it was born
between Ronald Reagan and Gorbachev and
and then more parties more members
joined so
it is a place of Peace in some sense
this being said of course there is also
some complexity coming with an
international collaboration with having
as a some degree of politics Associated
okay some compromises must be made so it
is not say the most efficient of the
organizations that you can imagine to
create an object of the kind but it is
part of its purpose projects like this
where you do sort of Frontier research
go through moments of Crisis sometimes
the moments of Crisis are of managerial
nature organizational nature sometimes
out of technical nature you know
building a device like this
always comes with big technical problems
even in the creation of This research
infrastructure so this is my priority
now it is to resolve these technical
problems this is a problem that came
because companies that were engaged in
the production of some components that
they never did before but hold on a
minute what exactly is nuclear fusion
well first of all let's be clear about
what it's not
this is different from nuclear fission
which involves splitting atoms apart
that's the reaction triggered in the
bombs dropped on Hiroshima and Nagasaki
in 1945 and also the reaction that
powers all the nuclear reactors
operating in the world today instead
nuclear fusion involves smashing atoms
into each other with such force that
they fuse releasing enormous amounts of
energy in the process first we know it
works because it's what powers the
universe all the stars that shine at
night are driven by Fusion Energy and
fusion is a process by its very name you
can sort of guess you take two small
objects and you push them together they
fuse into a bigger object and then the
equation most people maybe don't know
physics equations but they've heard E
equals m c squared which is energy is
equal to mass times the speed of light
times itself
that speed of light's a big number so if
you make a little change in mass you get
a big amount of energy so when you fuse
these two small objects together to make
a heavier one there's a little bit of
mass difference and that shows up as
energy from the reaction projects and
that's what we need to make heat
to move durbins to make electricity or
to make hydrogen for transportation Fuel
and that's the basic idea we use this
Mass change and it's a nuclear force
that we're using to make a large amount
of energy from a very small amount of
mass
following the first Fusion experiments
in the 1930s Fusion Laboratories were
established in nearly every
industrialized Nation a major
breakthrough occurred in 1968 in the
Soviet Union physicists Igor Tam and
Andre sakarov inspired by an original
idea from Oleg lavrantev introduced a
toroidal magnetic confinement device
that they called a Tokamak to make
energy from all this we need a machine a
machine that can reproduce the
incredible power of the process that
powers the sun within a single building
here on Earth
the most popular model being developed
by scientists at ETA and elsewhere is
the Tokamak a term dreamed up by Soviet
scientists in the 1950s
it describes a donut-shaped structure
with very powerful magnets known as
superconductors in the middle and around
the outside
the idea used in most Tokamak projects
is to take two different types of
hydrogen and mix them together in an
extremely hot plasma that's the fourth
state of matter in which charged
particles float around in a kind of soup
one of those isotopes of hydrogen is
called deuterium which has one proton
and one Neutron in its nucleus the other
one is called tritium and that has one
proton and two neutrons
the magnets keep the plasma suspended in
a vacuum without touching the walls of
the chamber
when the plasma is heated to a high
enough temperature the deuterium and
tritium atoms start fusing with each
other to form helium which has two
protons and two neutrons in its nucleus
that leaves an extra Neutron which gets
fired off into the walls of the reactor
generating heat and that heat if all
goes to plan can be used to generate
enormous amounts of electricity
[Music]
[Music]
dozens of tokamax have been built over
the years and many of them have
generated Fusion reactions but none has
yet given off more energy than it takes
in what is referred to in the industry
as net energy gain
the first time it has ever been done in
a laboratory
anywhere in the world
simply put this is one of the most
impressive scientific Feats of the 21st
Century
in December 2022 scientists at the U.S
government facility announced that they
had achieved that milestone for the
first time in history instead of a
Tokamak the team at California's
Lawrence Livermore National Laboratory
took a very different approach to Fusion
they used a massive laser array to fire
two megajoules of energy at a tiny metal
sphere containing deuterium and tritium
that triggered a fusion reaction that
gave off three megajoules of energy that
increase meant that a fusion reaction
with net energy gain had been achieved
but it's far from Clear how we could
build on this to create a working Power
Station those lasers consumed more than
300 megajoules of energy over a hundred
times more than they fired into that
metal sphere
so while net energy gain was achieved at
the fusion stage of the process the
system as a whole ate up far more energy
than it gave out there are very
significant hurdles not just in the
science but in technology this is one
igniting capsule one time and to realize
commercial Fusion Energy you have to do
many things you have to be able to
produce many many Fusion ignition events
per minute
scientists like Valentina nicolaiever
are hoping that after so many years of
work they may yet achieve the elusive
goal of net energy gain in a way that
would provide a blueprint for fusion
power plants that could be built in
large numbers generating vast amounts of
energy for households and businesses all
over the world
her decision to work in nuclear physics
was inspired by her father who took part
in the response to the nuclear disaster
at Chernobyl in 1986. my question was
like can we use something different and
he mentioned that in principle the three
main parameters are sufficiency
sustainability and safety we can have
something even more sufficient in theory
and much safer so it's not efficient of
very heavy nuclear but Fusion of very
light nuclear so that we don't have a
strong radiation we don't have
radioactive waste and
their Fusion foil can be taken just from
the sea water so in this case we would
have a safer source of energy that's
what we are doing here trying to build
this large-scale machine to prove and
demonstrate wave to have an efficient
fusion reaction which means that plasma
will hit itself so the produced energy
will be 10 times more than input energy
if something went wrong it stops
it just stops there's no there's no
potential for it to go out of control so
it's and from the reaction itself the
byproduct is helium we fill kids party
balloons with helium it's safe I mean
there's it's really
such a wonder you imagine you can't
imagine why we haven't done it before
well it's really hard and we have to
work hard at it and I think we will
succeed
[Music]
in any circumstances unlocking such a
powerful new source of energy would be a
massive development for human
civilization but as we grapple with the
worsening climate crisis and the need
for a rapid transition away from fossil
fuel energy the debate around fusion
power is gaining new intensity
some say that the priority has to be
doubling down on the low carbon
technologies that are already available
to us such as wind and solar and argue
that fusion power is a wacky distraction
that will always be decades away from
becoming a reality but to others Fusion
looks like a potentially game-changing
long-term answer to the twin problems of
climate change and energy security
solution to the energy transition is a
solution to energy security and I think
it's within within reach within the next
sort of eight to ten years if people
pull their fingers out I'm a
collaboration now we're starting between
the public lab and the private companies
and that's going to drive us towards
commercialization and that's what I
personally find very exciting we will
need multiple companies that are
successful and I'm very convinced that
that it will happen in the industry when
someone gets electricity onto the Grid
or even when someone shows that they can
get more energy out than they've put
into Fusion the whole field is it is
just going to Blossom
um and and it's going to attract more
investment while the intergovernmental
project at ETA is by far the larger
scale Fusion project in the world a
growing number of hotly funded private
sector startups are betting that they
can make faster progress
they've been deploying a range of
approaches to Fusion from lasers to
projectiles fired at enormous speeds but
so far the bulk of investment in this
space has gone to companies using
magnetic forces to create Fusion
reactions
among them is Tokamak energy a short
distance to the southeast of Oxford
refraction of a second in early 2022
this machine behind me contained the
hottest point of the entire solar system
100 million degrees Celsius that's about
five times hotter than the center of the
Sun and that was just one step towards
the dream that's driving this British
company unlocking the power of Fusion
Energy this is a huge milestone for us
it's the highest temperature plasma
temperature that's been measured in a
spherical Taco Mac and it's also the
highest temperature that's been achieved
by a privately funded Fusion company so
yeah we're pretty proud of that and it's
just a step on the way to continuing on
with our experiments we're trying to
create the conditions where pigeon can
happen my interest in patients died when
I was doing my gcses in school we were
lucky enough to have a fusion scientist
come and give us a talk so we kind of
learned a bit about Fusion in in our
science classes but on a very kind of
physics level whereas this talk showed
us the technology and the reactors and
this kind of things and just seeing they
see a kind of like scale scale of it I
really like doing experimental physics
and it's a massive experiment to be able
to to work out and I was like yes I want
to work on one of those I wanted to to
get into this field and do cool physics
but also hopefully make a difference
Hannah is one of a large number of young
scientists who have been drawn to this
field in the UK which has emerged as a
significant Hub of activity
the UK has invested heavily in Fusion
for the last 50 60 years and now we have
a regulatory environment that enables
commercial development of fusion well I
think private investors have become much
more interested in Fusion because of
technological advances like with the
superconducting magnets and also with AI
Control Systems and so forth and with
Advanced Materials coming through
so rather than it being something that's
purely The Preserve of the government
laboratory it becomes accessible to
privately funded innovators
and as we know the private Capital will
demand very rapid progress very
challenging Milestones not all the
private Ventures will succeed but those
that do will have a a big opportunity as
Fusion comes closer to commercialization
I think now is the time for Fusion to
move essentially from government
Laboratories into private companies a
bit like
space launchers 20 years ago where NASA
ended up working with SpaceX to develop
the next generation of space launchers
because it was basically too slow moving
itself to to make the progress necessary
and as we followed the large and
fast-growing sums of money flowing into
the fusion space it took us to Boston a
major U.S hub for both technology and
financial investment
cracking the fusion puzzle would create
a brand new commercial offering with a
vast potential market and for a growing
number of financial investors in cities
like Boston that is starting to look
like a seriously lucrative opportunity
one of the most high profile investors
in the green energy space is
breakthrough energy Ventures founded by
Bill Gates and backed by other
billionaires from Jeff Bezos to
masayoshi's son Phil larochelle who's
been leading breakthroughs investments
in this space says that Fusion is one of
the most exciting investment
opportunities around
so we have about two billion dollars
under management right now close to 100
companies and we tackle uh the five
biggest sectors of emissions which are
agriculture buildings electricity
manufacturing and transportation
Well Fusion I would put on the extreme
end of risk and reward
um so to talk about the reward
um you know I think people have
understood for a long time since
Eddington kind of explained what was
happening in the sun in the 1920s that
this was basically the way that the
Universe got its energy I mean well over
99 of the useful energy that has ever
come out in the universe has come from
Fusion people did Fusion in the 1930s
you know one of Rutherford students I
think kind of won the Nobel Prize for it
um so so doing Fusion is just
accelerating one thing into another and
with some probability some of them will
fuse
um the thing that's hard is to get
energy positive fusion and so that's
what people have been working on for
almost a century and so you know the
prize for Fusion is if the Industrial
Revolution was a thousand-fold increase
in energy density then this is a million
fold increase in energy density above
that and we have so much potential fuel
of it that it could basically last
forever and then when you do the energy
balance it looks like the fuel is
basically trivial compared to the amount
of energy you get out for it so so the
real payoff for Fusion is that the fuel
can be infinite
uh free
accessible to all
and potentially has no carbon emissions
and so when people ask me you know why
is it that you should be excited about
Fusion now or specifically the magnetic
confinement approach to Fusion I say
well it's kind of the same reason why
you should have been excited about
computers in the 1940s when someone
invented transistors at Bell Labs right
when you had to make computers out of
cranks and then you know vacuum tubes
you could only go so far right you were
never going to make an iPhone out of
vacuum tubes but the people who
understood the science of computers and
understood the potential for computers
understood that if you could replace a
vacuum tube which is kind of big kind of
clunky breaks a lot is slow generates
too much heat with a much better
equivalent then all of a sudden the
scientific curiosity would kind of
change the world
the same people are looking at fusion
and they're saying hey we understand how
these machines work and if we had a much
better magnet then all of a sudden maybe
this goes from science project to kind
of world-changing commercial technology
one of Phil's biggest bets to date has
been on a massachusetts-based company
called Commonwealth Fusion systems which
has raised about two billion dollars for
its technology using a new class of
superconducting magnets
this tape has a crystal in it that makes
it a superconductor that doesn't care
really at all about the magnetic field
so this this material Material Science
Innovation meant that if you could take
this material which you know it's not a
magnet it's a flimsy thing and learn how
to build magnets with it and vent
magnets on it that those magnets could
go to much higher magnetic fields than
before and that's what CFS did is we
took material like this there's some
other innovations that had to happen in
this material and then invented a whole
class of technologies that turned this
into a magnet that's double the magnetic
field of what happened before
that's generally useful but when applied
diffusion that that fact that it goes
like the minute I feel to the fourth
power that's a factor of 16. so if you
change something by a factor of 16 right
imagine if you're driving your car and
it's about 16 times faster that you know
a 20 mile an hour drive slowly turns
into 300 mile an hour drive like that is
a huge deal and that made these tokamax
you know really really attractive to
push to that final little Factor that's
needed to make more power out than in
and to make fusion power plants in a
commercial and economic package that you
could build a product in that you could
scale and that's that's what we're doing
foreign
to a little place called Devon's
Massachusetts about an hour outside
Boston to visit a construction project
that's all together different from any
other that I've visited before this is
where Bob mumgard and his team at CFS
say that in the next few years they're
going to create a fusion power reaction
that gives off more power than it
absorbs that's something the scientists
have been pursuing for decades these
guys say they can actually make it
happen
this is the spark Construction
so this all was a year ago a field
and now what we're building is we're
building the actual spark machine so
this is the building that will hold the
spark machine and actually standing
where they'll be you know power supplies
and Transformers that will manage the
power in and out of spark spark is a
demonstration right it is an integrated
demonstration that we can create the
conditions of an essay for Fusion to
work meaning we can get the temperature
the density and the insulation the
confinement all at the same time when we
do that we get more power out from the
plasma then went in Q grade and one net
energy Break Even those types of things
that's been a huge goal and that is when
you actually go from being a science
project to being something that is a
power plant-like thing and then in 2025
we'll we'll aim to turn it on meaning
like make the first plasmas on the path
to net energy soon thereafter so that's
a a pretty condensed timeline when you
think about us buying the site in 2021
and having a working Fusion system
making more power at the name in like
2025. so that's like four years this is
like what happens when you shrink the
scale and you put it into a very very
focused startup-like organization so you
know this is an impressive scale but
like this is a scale that you could
build around the world that we build
things around the world every day at
this scale and this is you know one
tenth the scale of the eater
construction site in France which is
building a token act to do net energy on
the same sort of physics that that we're
doing with spark but without that new
magnet technology
so amid all this excitement how soon
could commercial fusion power actually
become a reality
we're now at a place where the science
and component level advances and the
capital available now I think for the
first time makes it realistic that we
might be able to have commercial Fusion
reactors knock on wood
by uh by the 2030s I think maybe sooner
but I think 2030s at least you kind of
have a believable story that if we
tackle some challenges it might happen
if you're talking about making
electricity we could make electricity in
the presence of fusion power now if
you're talking about a plant that
generates electricity
more than it takes to to run the plant
itself
you know 2050s probably if you're
talking about
one percent five percent of the world's
electricity capacity by Fusion you need
time to develop an industry you know
there have to be successive Generations
so probably it's I would love for it to
be during this Century but probably
toward the end of this Century till you
could get a real fusion economy going
you have to have a robust system of
drivers to enable that so you know
probably decades we're looking at a
Pilot prompt uh delivering power to the
grid by 2032 and then scaling up for
Global deployment by 2040. so this is a
potential solution to the challenge of
deep decarbonization
2035 24 T out to 2050 sort of deployment
time I don't think it will happen in my
lifetime
it's uh it's you know when I started
this I thought so I thought we would be
able to make it I see that it's it has
uh
degrees of complexity just by the nature
of the process I've started working in
order to address the problem of global
warming but I don't think that the
fusion will contribute in the short term
we understand that global warming is a
problem now if you want to make a
difference on climate change now you're
going to have to ask people to make a
change in their lifestyle Energy
Efficiency likely isn't going to be
enough for me Fusion if we
do make a choice now
to impact climate change
there'll be a sacrifice Fusion gives the
hope that that sacrifice doesn't need to
be forever
[Music]
fusion power is not going to make a
meaningful impact on the climate crisis
or on energy Security in the near time
but an impressive number of leading
scientists entrepreneurs and investors
are making serious commitments in search
of what could be a major breakthrough
for the long-term future of human
civilization and that for me makes this
one of the most intriguing areas of
technology to watch
this was the first film in a three-part
series please make sure to like comment
and share
[Music]